Lori thanks so much for coming on
um so I I hope uh that what you're
seeing in the response to that segment
is a really deep love of animals who are
in some ways the weakest among us we can
do whatever we want to animals so it's a
measure of our decency what we do to
animals it's a measure of the fact that
Americans still love animals
Tucker we cannot thank you enough
for airing this story and it has helped
us with your extremely generous
dog-loving viewers it is going to let us
save so many more and also allow us to
go back to the Border
we've currently got about 900 dogs
between our Palm Beach County and
Alabama facility which all need medical
care and this is starting off our new
year in a great way and it's just really
heartwarming to me to see how many
people have reached out to help donate
and adopt and it's because of all of you
that many dogs will be loved and have a
chance at a wonderful new home
I think it's meaningful that you're a
no-kill shelter I mean without judgment
there are a lot of different kinds of
shelters but I think people feel good
about giving to a shelter that really is
about dogs and about loving them and
keeping them alive and not disposing of
them
there are so many dogs still being
surrendered because of inflation the
high cost of rent fuel groceries
everything and shelters are so
overcrowded right now so the need for
rescue the need for us to grow and save
more is at an all-time high and we're
just extremely grateful to all of you
that join our cause whether you donate
volunteer adopt and thank you so very
very much for getting this out because
people need to know there's wonderful
dogs out there that need homes don't buy
from a breeder spay and neuter your pets
let's in this problem of dog
homelessness and
the dogs need us and we're thankful for
all of you
they love us unconditionally we should
love them back I think that's true Laura
great to see you thank you for what
you're doing
and happy New Year and thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight